welcome back gamers to another mr. beast
gaming video hi here's the deal me and
100 minecraft players were riding on a
plane but the plane crashed in the
middle of nowhere and now we're trapped
and stranded and here's the problem I
have $10,000 in my pocket and whoever's
last to die gets it and let's begin all
right we're gonna start it off by giving
this guy a diamond sword let's see what
he does I gave all 100 players leather
armor and wood swords and currently PvP
is off as you can see we're gonna turn
PvP on for 1 minute it is on all right
have fun boys the war has begun there's
100 players here are they gonna for
faction or are they gonna Duke it out
what will happen oh the guy with the
iron sword is going after everyone cuz
he has a much better sword
oh he just killed somebody these guys
are teaming any wait I found Carl get
away
I'm gonna hit Chandler just for fun
whoops PvP is now off as you can see you
can't hurt each other we're gonna turn
it on intervals bro I just farted you a
translator you just farted alright this
guy on our team get out we don't want
you no no I'm a big see ya big ceeze
epic it's been a minute I'm gonna press
the button and turn on PvP now PvP is
back on oh look at these guys these guys
are teaming up together oh wait they're
teaming up to beat this guy up oh oh
this kid doesn't even have a sword
do they not chris is a war about to
break out oh I gave him a diamond sword
he doesn't care anymore alright that
seems odd that seemed pretty upbeat the
diamond sword guys swung at Carl always
a garbage man he's trying to use it on a
a diamond helmet Oh diamond chestplate
Oh
diamond boots Oh little ants you need
loot did he die no it's just Calphalon
up they explained to me that they're
dropping good I wanted that oh hey who's
that who's that this is a guy who wants
to win that's a no and there's a boy
Jedi the guy who won 10 grand here dude
wait so you're telling me he's straight
jump there
he would have missed he would have died
mmm boy Jedi censure reoccurring
character here's a bow and here's some
arrows oh he wants that helmet that's
why you here how about this let's help
this guy out
I'm gonna give him stuff now yes full
diamond is never proper here for him
pick it up you noob hahaha
put it on oh my gosh no that he's gonna
get another type of chest plate
all right here I'm gonna try to help him
with this there's a boat pick it oh yeah
he's super opiate so whoever kills for
aid gets $5,000 oh you're putting a hit
out on I'm putting a hit out of them
Oh Oh somebody got sniped from where
from up there in the tower oh oh this
guy this guy right here got it
congratulations you just won $5,000 oh
boy Jenny's going after Carl it looks
antler stop did they take it
Oh explain yourself what happened me and
Chandler's plan was to pretend to team
with people and then kill them and then
he just killed me before it happened all
right we're gonna help ya well we're
gonna give you creative mode now so
don't worry oh no this guy dude this guy
got Carl's gear dude look Chandler
barely survived that fall are you okay I
died I know I saw you Carl
yes I need you to start blocking off the
outer edges of the map it's too big
ruining people's days I love it hey
buddy you want a Ravager I'm gonna spawn
a bunch of these in the middle and then
put Opie loot inside of it
full set of diamond gear in the middle
what I spawned three Ravagers in an area
and they all just came together and
killed one person a full set of diamond
gears in the middle who will be brave
enough to go after it bro
Oh
Oh someone went for it oh no dude is he
gonna get it oh it he got away Oh Gavin
once it is he is kicking him oh no Gavin
just got a full set of diamond gear I'll
try him the guy who won five grand he's
getting double-teamed all right
um it's hiding of Amir come on come on
no need to be he wants that money man
you got a hide for that money I'm about
to force them off this mountain don't
worry I'll be forcing them soon I'm just
getting the barrier so you guys made it
so hard for me jailor know that Ravager
came up from behind while you were
eating also Carl you got
- my boy Jetta we got make sure Big C to
see when it's okay soup after watching
help make sure you help Big C out
there's currently 12 players left it
looks like a lot of the remaining people
still have diamond armor do a lot of
remains of other innocent dead minecraft
players do this guy Amit is just chillin
at the spot we show there's still 10 to
12 people left they're very scattered so
here's what we're gonna do dropping
Kapil's and spawn in 30 seconds moving
in and chat I I think that whoever gets
that gamble is definitely gonna have a
big advantage and probably go for the
dub this is gonna be fun I have the
Golden Apple there waiting for it and
lucky they're looking at me and
cowabunga
oh it's right in the center creepers a
ram oh oh we got it
okay okay I'm gonna drop another one try
got it Oh Gavin lots gonna get this one
with ease you have two minutes to kill
someone if you don't you lose this is
gonna weed out the weak let's go oh he
just stayed AG Apple ran as soon as he
saw over here someone's probably gonna
target and emit here emit I gotta help
him it out you go admit you need some
help everybody's running away from the
kid who ate the gap yeah that's why we
got a shrink this places to be trying to
give you armor admit my god just way
insane well at least the ravager gets to
stay in the game the Ravagers are good
this guy still has leather armor how is
he still in well gavotte has something
to say about his leather armor oh
they're duking it out fight fight fight
fight no no don't be a don't run away
Duke it up oh oh okay oh he's using the
lava to kill the Ravagers he's smart
knowledge big C is sniping oh he's going
for the kill
oh he's eating the gap oh oh really
lava how many people are left for all
right here's what we're gonna do lava
turn off PvP is big see one of them yeah
Big C is one school you've already won
$5,000 in this video and if you win this
duel here you can win another $10,000
yeah so you can walk away today with 15
grand if you play your cards right yeah
that's more than Carl's everyone hey Big
C
so big see all just joined the discord
now big see you do realize that if you
beat these guys in PvP you get a walk
away with $10,000 cash that's crazy
ten big ten McFlurry ten french fries
hey John how's it going yeah what's up
oh you also share name with me Jimbo
I'm Jimmy John I just wanted to let you
know before we proceed further that
$10,000 is on the line
and these three guys are all that are in
the way okay we have all four
contestants here eenie meenie miney moe
catch a tiger by its toe if he hollers
let him go eeny meeny miny moe all right
I landed on you a big seed who do you
want to pick no offense John but you're
the only one in love there boots so I'm
gonna take on you
all right big C versus John is our first
challenge and the winner of Big C versus
John will face the winner of try n
versus gavotte for $10,000 I had
everybody get into a corner all right
three two one duel don't forget that
you're practically playing Minecraft for
a car right now come on Jimbo come on
Big C come on John hey fake it till you
make it you're techno played each other
for 10 grand
oh you take it a lot teleported back
into his cage
all right try vs Gavin how about some
trash talk boys yeah you suck your
respective corner okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna drop a lava bucket and
go I don't know if that lava bucket will
do anything but it's in the middle oh
we've got him on the soul sand they're
just having a whacking match Oh
$10,000 is online
oh I'm gonna wait for his resistance to
warn oh yeah he just told you his plan
go rule number one never tell the enemy
your plan and also don't tell them that
you're lagging yeah I'm getting like
free stops on stun East oh right well
that's part of the challenge or Oh
sounds like you guys both have equal
lags I'll try
you can't no try here's the deal yeah
you at least won $5,000 earlier in the
video so yeah at least you have that
that's true yeah Thank You Carl did you
just give them arrows you didn't have
favoritism I'm not favoriting visible
Dixie this is probably the most
important thing you'll ever do in your
life most likely yes
you got this ten thousand smackeroonies
you do you realize how much money that
is
I see a lot of money guys three to skip
a few would lava go where to make it
more interesting
oh not with the bows is that flame used
up oh these are minecraft rows okay
big soul sandwich see it's taken some
time being helped one out get that you
got this don't worry no he's on fire now
you gotta push push push good he's going
who will win the fight
big ceeze on fire covered in arrows Big
C is on fire affordable win this this is
like Call of Duty dynamic changing maps
we're gonna lay more lava in both
corners all right there we go
makes my god Dixie gonna be Big W he's
trying to push him into the lava yeah
with the plate
go back up oh wait he has AG Apple so he
probably has fire immunity Gavit we're
like grab that $10,000 am i right
God is o doing means eating again oh my
gosh oh no wait oh and I'm putting a
bunch of creepers down you got this you
got it - what Ravager is in the mouth
looks like he wants big seed bit oh nice
alright look the Revengers guarding this
side of the map oh he's got them in the
Groves
also I love you Gavin I'm sorry over
here dig see see see thank you everyone
so much for watching and we'll see you
in the next video subscribe